I have to say that I had a video back then
that went viral overnight with
the first lockdown. I can
remember that all the
gyms were closed like that back then and then
suddenly this one video went out that was
older, it was two years old and
that  then I had no idea 8000 views
and after that it
suddenly had 200,000 and then it went
up to 300,000 suddenly it had a
million that was also that was a
CrossFit home workout and there was
really nothing on YouTube, that means
all the crossfitters were then maybe
that's okay  I want to make a video now
and that was my
push on YouTube again where I thought
okay, I have to use that now and
I also posted from DAH every day and that
took a very
long time